so I mean okay thanks
so it's pleasure to be here thanks for
the invitation we Peter and I put a deck
of slides it's just one deck and we try
to make notation and we'll be swapping
at arbitrary points in time just like in
hockey if I get tired yeah
or you get tired with my Russian accent
you can get a bit of Australian accent
all right so this tutorial will cover a
few topics most many of them are
classical topics we'll start with
introduction we'll talk about inform
laws of large numbers we'll talk about
classification and then we'll discuss
methods that are not just about
minimizing empirical risk local methods
will discuss stability and maybe this
time we'll discuss compression these are
different approaches for obtaining
generalization bounds as a
numbers and then if there is time will
we're hoping to do a little bit of kind
of modern take on these problems and
under the name of interpolation okay so
that's that's the that's the goal please
interrupt me at any time if you have
some questions I don't mind just raise
your hand okay so what does
generalization let's start okay so we
observe some examples and then we make
conclusions right so it's a year we
observe an example and we make a
conclusion that is a log of the sum is
the sum of the walls it's true never
start with a joke of course one example
is not enough so when you we need more
examples to generalize so we get more
examples and it just works all the time
hopefully all of these correct okay so
what is the setup under which we're
going to be working the aim is to
predict an outcome Y from some set
script Y of possible outcomes on the
basis of an observation X and to do that
just as in the previous example we have
a set of n pairs input/output pairs x
and y and we would like to choose a
function f from the mapping from x to y
so that when we observe some input X we
are ready to predict the outcome Y and
and F is our algorithm F is the function
that we compute from the day much of
this is very basic and so I'm gonna go
quickly but if you end up being lost
please stop me at any time
so to quantify how good our prediction
is we're choosing a loss function the
loss function maps the prediction and
the actual outcome to a number which
quantifies how well we we predict
the y-variable from the X and our aim
given the presentation is to ensure that
this loss of f of X comma Y is small so
given an X we compute f of X that's our
prediction and then we compare it to the
outcome Y and we would like this to be
small
what are some examples of the of these
loss functions in pattern
classifications or classification we try
to classify X into a number a couple of
or a handful of classes this is a binary
classification example with two classes
0 & 1
and it's simply an indicator of whether
we got the label correct or not so it's
we will call it the indicator loss in
regression problems the the set of
values that we're trying to predict as a
real line or belongs to the real line
and so it makes sense to take a square
loss and that leads to regression
problems okay hopefully this is very
basic and you've probably seen example
what is less obvious is how to formulate
the prediction problem in in a sensible
way and one way to do it is using a
probabilistic assumption so we will
posit that there is a probability
distribution on X Y X cross Y and what
we observe are examples x1 y1 xn yn
chosen independently from the same
distribution so these are iid examples
and we observe n of them and and just
for simplicity we'll have a X Y another
X Y pair again chosen independently with
the same distribution and our aim is to
choose a function that has a small risk
which is the expected loss of a
prediction f of X on a new X variable
when the outcome is y so this
expectation is under the
distribution and under the draw of a
tuple X Y okay in the pattern
classification example this is the
probability of incorrectly classifying
the example so 0 1 there as a subscript
the 0 1 loss is just the expected loss
it's expected loss that f of X is not
equal to Y which is that f of X is not
equal to I so this coincides with our
notion that we would like to choose F
such that on a new example X drawn from
the same population the prediction will
match the y variable and we'll pay for
the the mass of the measure of being
incorrect ok questions about the set up
on the the probabilistic assumption is
is the most widespread assumption in in
in machine learning I guess there are
other setups where you can formulate the
problem of learning without this
probabilistic assumption but for now we
will stick so why do we make this
probabilistic assumption well it's
because we would like this set of
examples and examples that we've
observed to be somehow connected to this
X Y right if there's no connection
between the N examples and the next one
on which we will be present tested then
we can't say anything in general right
so we have to make an assumption that
what we observe the examples that we
observed look like the one on which we
will be tested
[Music]
yes sir so there has been work on in the
direction becomes more much more
complicated quickly something called
adaptation Thank You only talk about the
the setup where examples come from the
distribution on which we will be tested
okay so we have to be in the set of mind
that we observe let's say the problem is
the class to classify images dogs vs.
cats we have to pretend somehow that the
data set that we've got is an ID draw
from this population of cats and dogs
and then we will be tested on a random
draw from the same population now
whether you buy into the setup or not
that's a different story but that's what
we're gonna do
right other questions and so the most
natural question is why not a estimate
the underlying distribution P from which
these examples are drawn or why not
estimate the conditional distribution of
Y given X and then if you if you've got
a good estimate of this probability
distribution then of course you can
attempt to minimize on this previous
slide you can attempt to minimize this
expected loss however it's easy to see
that this is an overkill this is a more
general problem in or it's a harder
problem than the problem of prediction
and kind of the basic example is you
know think of X as being cats and dogs
cats live here in the space of images
dogs live here and if I were to estimate
the distribution I would really need to
go after these miniscule features of
these distributions but all I care for
the decision problem is the boundary
okay so the trying to estimate the
boundary or trying to get a sense of
where the boundary between cats and dogs
lie lies it is an easier problem than
trying to estimate the actual
distributions of the castle those is a
class conditional densities
all right so of course we understand
that the the key difficulty here is that
the the goal of minimizing out-of-sample
performance or performance on data that
we haven't seen is that this data comes
from an unknown distribution P and we
don't know what it is so we have to use
some empirical data instead and and this
is where statistics comes in and lots of
quantities that will define do come from
statistics are from applied probability
and ways of controlling them falls into
the purview of so what we can do is for
a mapping from X to Y we can calculate
the empirical loss of this decision f of
X and compare it to the Y variable and
that's the empirical quality of our
solutions so if you were if F is a
neural network that map's images of cats
and dogs into a decision of 0 on 1 or
minus 1 1 then this is your training
loss for a model F ok that's your
training loss and and maybe it makes
sense to minimize it may be enough we
have to be careful about dependence of
the function on the data so from now on
I will put a hat on on F to signify that
this function is a model learned from
the data so even though we write f of X
what we're a meeting is that this f of X
or F hat of X has been computed based on
the data it has been computed from the
data and therefore the data are random
and therefore the function is random so
you have to get them the in this mode of
thinking of the outcome as a random
function even though the whole learning
process might be completely
deterministic but the data are random it
is a draw from this underlying
population and therefore what we get is
a is a
random function so the risk which is the
expected loss of the expected future
loss of the function loss on the new
example from the same population we're
gonna write conditioned on the data and
this expectation is just over the XY
pair just remind you that the f hat is
computed based on so L of F hat n is a
random variable and therefore to make
sure that this is small the the
prediction on the new example is small
we need to somehow quantify that as a
random variable so it can be small in
expectation or it can be small with high
probability
very we will most of the time talk about
expected L being small because then
there are other arguments to show that
because of concentration the random
quantity L of F hat is concentrated L
and it's also small okay questions you
could you could have an algorithm that
uses some randomization such a
stochastic wave in the Sun and that
would add one more random variable into
the story nothing would change
other questions okay quiz what is random
L hat of F for a given F random or not F
is fixed I give you a particular a
neural network that I let's say I
initialized and just gave you is L of L
hat of F random yes because nation hears
L hat that depends on the data how about
F hat yeah I just told you that that's
random f hat sub n is random L hat of F
hat is the empirical loss or build
empirical error of the Lots a neural
network if your home we're here for
learning so f hat is near is a random
function f hat is the empirical
performance of the the output of the
learning procedure so that's also a
random quantity L of F hat yes
how about L of F for fixed F no okay
you're all passed it's important to keep
in mind what is random just because you
know there will be a lots of kind of
probabilistic statements here so how do
we analyze F hat n that's our trained
model from the from the data for these
squares it has a closed form solution at
least in the
low-dimensional regime you can write
like that
and analysis somehow is often easier not
always but often is easier if your
solution has a closed form it's a
regression problem you can have a closed
form solution you write it down you you
you analyze it turn the crank and that
that's easier unfortunately for most
machine learning problems these are
procedures that are not explicitly
defined but are solutions to an
optimization of the optimization
objectives such as train a neural
network on on the data and it even be an
iterative procedure without an
immediately obvious objectives such as
audibles random forests and and so that
is the difficulty where algorithm how
you train it needs to be considered
together with the space of possible
values for this function so what is the
gold standard what what what is the best
we can hope for let's call a Bayes
optimal function it's the art min of
expected loss over all measurable
prediction rules that map X to Y so if
if I were God I would be able to compute
for the distribution of cats and dogs
the best decision boundary overall
prediction and why is the loss of app
star not equal to zero necessarily
because there is some noise in the
process so some cats might look like a
dog some dogs might look like a cat and
so even the best decision boundary might
incur a certain the base error is this
absolute minimum that we can hope to
achieve lff star and it once again we
cannot calculate this quantities these
are just for analysis purposes because
the some examples if our problem is that
of binary classification with 0 1 as the
process then the Bayes decision boundary
is just a threshold the indicator that
the regression function is more than one
half whether the regression function is
the conditional expectation of Y given X
so if for a given X the mean value of
the class is more than 1/2
we should classify it as class 1 if it's
less than 1/2 then we classified as a
that's the best you can hope for and for
the problem of regression the base
optimal function is the regression
function itself again it's the expected
value of y given that X is equal to X so
think of this the regression function as
the average value of the outcome
variable conditionally on X being a
certain value right so that's a function
of X all right
so the big question that we consider in
this tutorial is how to construct a
learning algorithm with a guarantee that
AgrAbility on in the expectation the
loss of the model that we learn from
data minus this baseline the best you
can hope for is small so we're
approaching the best possible
so here it's defined as minimization
over all measurable functions so this is
really the the lowest you can in the
second will restrict to a class and then
now let me just let me just mention that
there are two types of inequalities that
we will consider so one is this type of
out-of-sample performance of our model
is comparable to Elif webstore plus
something and another one that we will
get is L of F hat and is upper bounded
by some empirical quantity that you can
compute from the data that may go to 0
in a particular setup okay and then we
can once we get there we can have a
discussion so some function sense
function of data this could be margin
loss or empirical loss if you've seen
quantities and and then we can have a
discussion whether for the deep learning
application it makes sense to aim for
such a goal or for
yes so this is out-of-sample so we're
hoping we're hoping that out-of-sample
performance of the model learned from
the data is no more than some function
that depends on the data and that's
something that you can compute and
observe to this small okay so just keep
in mind that there are these two
possibilities and when we talk about
margin classification with a margin loss
we'll talk about this all right so um
and now there is a notion of consistency
which is to say if I get enough data
with enough data I will approach this
gold standard I will approach this Bayes
optimal loss and that's called Universal
consistency and the good news is that
it's very easy to achieve or easy but
it's possible to achieve in the sense
that with enough data you will get to
this optimal function as under some
basic assumptions that the underlying
relationship between the X and Y is
continuous and you can you can see that
you know with infinitely many cats and
many dogs you should be able to get you
know to the best possible boundary
that's consistency the result is
asymptotic and it's of perhaps limited
interest because because it doesn't
really tell you how quickly we get to
this gold standard what is the number of
samples we need it doesn't doesn't shed
light on the on the learning process and
in fact the the bad news is that there
is nothing interesting that can be said
about the this rate of convergence of
the out-of-sample performance of our
model to the best unless we make further
assumptions about the distribution in
other words unless
we have some prior knowledge about this
the the learning problem no free lunch
theorem say that for any algorithm and
any M and any epsilon the toothpicks
there will be a probability distribution
such that the performance of your
algorithm that you just gave me is
essentially chance I'm being a little
bit vague here but you can look this up
in the literature this is an even
stronger for any algorithm and any
sequence decreasing to zero there is a
probability distribution such that
out-of-sample is zero but for all an
expected performance is no faster to
create decaying no faster than the
sequence that you've chosen this seems
like a strong negative result which says
that you can't if you fix an algorithm
there will be some bad probability
distribution that will prevent you from
saying anything interesting about the
speed of convergence of your algorithm
but in fact you can also say that the
these no free lunch theorems are really
corner cases because we always have some
prior knowledge about the problem some
prior knowledge about the distribution
and and the goal is to really see what
what kind of assumptions can we make
about the problem which are not too hard
they're not really modeling every little
aspect of the problem which would might
be able to which we might get wrong but
on the other hand they they would allow
us to say something useful about the
learning process okay yes that's the
questions about this
these theorems assume that conditional
in the data that the model is
deterministic or the whether you have an
demised all worth noting will not matter
here but it does of course play on the
fact that Y is a random variable given X
okay so it's it's not really bad news
because we always have some domain
knowledge about the problem or we can we
can try to posit some assumptions that
will exclude these corner cases and
these know very large theorems will be
will not be applicable and there are
several ways of incorporating prior
knowledge about the problem one is a
direct way it's an assumption about the
distribution P and if you're coming from
the Bayesian background of course here
you say of course we always do that and
the goal for us is going to be not
assume anything about the particular
shape of the distribution so for
instance I don't want to assume that the
distribution of cats and the
distribution of dogs and in that high
dimensional space has a certain shape I
don't want to do that but maybe we will
try to assume something about the margin
between the distributions of the cats
and the distribution of the dogs don't
overlap too much assumption that is more
mild than an assumption about the shape
of the distribution we might make
assumption about the smoothness of the
regression function smoothness of the
boundary between classes and so forth so
that's that's a direct way an indirect
way of incorporating prior knowledge is
to redefine the goal to to try to
compete in terms of the prediction error
with the best decision in some smaller
class of models so you would like to to
ensure that the expected loss of the
model that you learn is comparable to
the best model within the class script F
of models and this is what vapnik would
call in an inductive bias and often will
make in fact both of these assumptions
will have a will have both of these
assumptions playing different roles or
you know and Hulst questions
okay so what I would like to do next is
to discuss perceptron which is the the
beginning of machine learning perhaps
goes back to the 50s I how many of you
have not seen perceptron how many of you
cannot prove okay how many of you can
prove the mistake bound for a perceptron
now all right so okay so the next thing
about perceptron is it's super simple
you can get a generalization bound or
the out-of-sample performance guarantee
with just a few lines and there are
certain aspects in this perceptron
problem which are already present in in
in this problem when we go to neural
networks right perceptron is just the
one layer neural net right without the
hidden unit and many of the aspects will
be that we'll discuss our over again
there okay so what does a perceptron you
have two classes say cats and dogs and
what we will be assuming is that there
is a no-man's land between these cats
and dogs so there is a margin of gamma
this is the pictorial definition of
margin such that there are no cats in
this no-man's land and all dogs
more precisely consider a sequence of
pairs x1 y1 X T YT here T is a different
index it may or may not be the same as n
the number of examples and we will
maintain it will be an online method and
so we will maintain a hypothesis WT
which is just a vector in Rd which we
will initialize at a 0 on round T we
will consider the next couple the next
tuple XT YT and we will form a
prediction based on the current sign of
WT x xt so we will look at the
hyperplane for the given XT we will see
whether we classify the this point
correctly and if not then we will do an
update we'll make an update WT plus 1 is
WT plus y T XT and this can be seen as a
gradient step on a hinge at 0 loss if
you are familiar with this if the
prediction is correct then we will not
update the hyperplane and this is very
important
perception update rule okay so
pictorially at time T we've observed a
certain sequence of data this is the
current hypothesis WT it's a normal to
the hyperplane new XT comes it's on this
side of the hyperplane so we say a cat
and then if it is a cat we don't do
anything but if it's a dog then we will
move it's incorrect so we will move the
WT towards XT by adding that provides a
certain correction it doesn't it doesn't
mean that this example will be correctly
classified but at least it moves in that
direction more precisely the margin is
defined as a so what is this notion of a
no-man's land it's the best direction
that you can choose such that for the
worst point what is the positive part of
why I wxi that is exactly the projection
of X I onto the W then looking at
whether it corresponds to the sign of Y
I and paying if it doesn't correspond to
the sign then paying sorry if it
corresponds to the to the correct sign
then it's a positive number and then you
do get a certain non zero value if for
that W it's on the wrong side of the
hyperplane this is zero
in which case the margin is going to be
zero okay so this is just a more
complicated way of explaining that
picture and in 1962 Novikov and I think
block as well I haven't tracked down
that reference proved that the
perceptron algorithm that I described
before converges sorry let's not talk
about convergence perceptron makes it
most one over gamma squared mistakes on
any sequence of examples with margin
gamma so this is a fully deterministic
result
you pick any sequence of XY pairs that
has a margin gamma and you don't need to
know gamma ahead of time as long as this
margin is nonzero perceptron will make
no more than 1 over gamma squared so
hopefully most of you have seen this
result should I go through the proof
it's really a three in line proof I look
at a time point when the mistake was
made so that means that there is a
correction to the hyperplane WT plus 1
is equal to that because the correction
is made and we open up the squares you
get that and that's upper bounded this
is one so we're assuming that the data
lives in a bowl and that's upper bounded
by just the norm WT squared because this
is this one that is quantity because
there was a mistake and therefore the
length squared of your WT vector is no
more than M where m is the number of
mistakes after T iterations on the other
hand if you track the angle between the
W star and the updates then we know the
W star that's the optimal hyperplane has
to have a margin at least gamma we write
out the recursion do the telescoping and
get that the M times gamma is no more
than square root of M and then the
result follows ok so if you haven't seen
this you can look at the slide at home
this is a very simple argument we don't
have to assume that data X lives in a
bowl so this is a more slightly more
general result to recap for any sequence
of XY pairs the number of mistakes made
by the perceptron is no more than d
squared over gamma squared where D is
the radius of the data so it's a maximal
norm of
and gamma is that the size of the
no-man's land between the classes
questions about this yes that's correct
so if you want well if gamma is 0 then
this bound is useless so for this to
make sense to be non infinity you do
need gamma to be larger than 0 versions
of what open America that way so that's
correct sir so I will make I will show
you two consequences one is when you do
one pass through the data and the other
one when you cycle through the data
until you make no more mistakes so let
me do that now
but let me also say that the the WT
vector when you do this one pass or
multiple paths so WT vector doesn't
necessarily converge to the W star the
optimal high so it doesn't maximize the
margin for that you need a different
loss if you consider loss that has tails
such that it's never stopping to to do
the update you will converge under some
conditions
for any sequence of data for any
sequence I'm gonna do so there's a there
is this capital T for a purpose it's not
necessarily M so all I'm saying is fix
any sequence of data you might have the
repetitions there because I'm not making
any assumptions on the data it's fully
deterministic result i if it has a
certain margin you will not make more
than one over gamma squared okay so
let's do the first consequence you do
one pass over the data and so now you
have actually have n data points and now
I'm gonna bring back the iid nature of
this data okay so these are actually
drawn from this distribution P and we
will just do one pass and so the claim
is that the expected error or expected
indicator loss of a randomly picked
function there's a sequence of w's from
1 to n and I'm gonna pick one uniformly
at random I've run the algorithm the
perceptron algorithm on these data which
are now iid and then I go back and I
just pick one at random and the claim is
that that's a good enough for government
work so the claim is that the
performance of that randomly chosen
function an expectation is 1 over N
times whatever this quantity is why is
there expectation because D is really
property now of this data and gamma is
the function of the data as well as the
margin in the date
okay the proof was very simple it's
really just rewriting things so we know
that the result holds without
expectations
it's a turistic result applied to that
sequence length N and we're just
dividing by little N and taking
expectation on both sides so let's just
rewrite the left-hand side as an
expectation where tau is the random
index that's exactly the 1 over N sum
that's a uniformly randomly chosen index
tau so this left hand side is simply
expected over tau expected over a data
set the they did you make an error using
W tau on the example X tau Y tau is not
less than 0 and that's the same as the
indicator of a mistake and now there is
this kind of a magic trick a sleight of
hand to say that well W tau hasn't seen
the X tau Y tau yet because that's
computed based on the previous and so I
can just replay we name this into X Y
has the same distribution and so what
we've got is precisely the expected over
tau expected over the data set 0 1 loss
of this randomly chosen - and the right
hand side is exactly so so this is a
one-line proof
probably the simplest generalization
bound you can ever get I don't know of
any simpler generalization but the
second consequence is a little bit more
interesting we'll do multiple passes
through the data and so T that capital T
is no more than n times d squared over
gamma squared so the worst thing that
can happen I do a pass over data and I
just make one correction in this pass I
do another pass I do one correction so I
can I can more I can make at least so T
is at most n times d squared over gamma
squared for that reason but it doesn't
matter we're not gonna use this back and
now I'm gonna output the final
hyperplane of the perceptron right so
yeah I have these data I just go over
them again and again and again again
until I found a separating hyperplane
that separates cats and dogs it's not a
maximum margin hyperplane but the claim
is that that's good enough that has a
good out-of-sample performance now just
I just want to say that this is not an
obvious statement so imagine that you
didn't know about this and try to prove
the prove the results so you have the
suppose data live on the sphere and this
is the support of the cats and this is
the support of the dogs
and what you observe is just the Sam of
course you don't know the support you
don't know the distribution but you
observe some cats and some dogs and now
you start making the corrections until
you've perfectly separated the data now
it could be that this is the hyperplane
that you output and and and it cuts into
the wrong class so if you were to if you
didn't know the the result that I'm
gonna show you and you just try to prove
it you would say okay I really have to
quantify how much I would cut and of
course if there is a data point here I
wouldn't cut it because if the
hyperplane has to be on the other side
but it gets really messy right just to
give you a sense that this is a not an
obvious you know thing to do if you if
you do if you didn't go this route
now of course you can say well it's just
empirical minimizer so empirical
minimizer is the one that minimizes the
number of mistakes in the data but it's
one of the empirical minimizer's there
are there are many of them that there's
a wiggle room of at least two gamma
there and there are lots of them and I'm
gonna present analysis only for the
final perceptron it's the one that you
the perceptron outputs so the claim is
that the out-of-sample zero one loss for
for the final output is at most one over
N and plus one times again this expected
d squared over gamma squared so what's
the proof the proof is really neat
instead of XY pairs let's just call them
Z's as a shorthand okay and instead of
writing indicator of a mistake so a
mistake is y times W times X is less
than zero that that's one mistake occurs
I'm just gonna write L of W comma Z okay
then what we're gonna do is we're gonna
write they expected over the data set
expected over this new tuple X Y which
we'll call Z loss of the final
perceptron as a bunch of believe what
we'll leave one out right so what W
minus T is is the output of the final
perceptron when it's run repeatedly on
the data you leave the cheap one out
okay so you take n plus 1 data points n
plus 1 random draws from the
distribution you leave the ZT out and
then you run many many times until
convergence no more mistakes
so why can I do it like that well it's
easy to convince yourself of the pack
because all of them are IID is just a
renaming M plus one when you didn't
leave anything out but you tested on the
last one right so all of them are the
same this is just to say that leave one
out is an unbiased estimate of the
expected loss okay so this is the only
part where we need to think a little bit
so now consider running perceptron
repeatedly on the n plus 1 data points
until there are no more errors and let I
won through I M be the indices on which
perceptron makes an error on any of the
passes through these n plus 1 points
okay so if 1/100 paths I ended up
correcting a certain example making a
mistake I mark that place okay good
so what we know is that M is less than Z
squared over gamma squared which is a
property of n plus 1 data points
but now let's think about an index which
is not in one of these places where a
mistake is made now whether the ZT was
included in the data set or was not
included in the data set doesn't matter
because you never made a correction you
never make an error on that ZT and in
particular if you if you didn't have it
in the data set and you ran until
convergence and then tested on that ZT
you wouldn't have an error because you
never make an error on that so that ZT
is correctly classified by this w that
leaves out the T so this quantity is
upper bounded by this gamma squared
divided by n it is again the shortest
proof possible I know of that's kind of
non-trivial where you get a
out-of-sample bound on the final output
of your learning algorithm where a
direct analysis would be kind of messy
questions about this
that dimension doesn't show up anywhere
just that's my next slide thank you
or one more slide okay just a few
remarks in this case the Bayes error is
zero because we have to assume margin
and the distribution sample where there
is no margin our bound is infinity
immediately our assumption about the
distribution was not about the
parametric or non parametric form we
didn't assume that the two classes are
Gaussian or or whatever what we assumed
is what happens at the boundary and
that's kind of a signature of results in
learning theory we try to assume what's
happening in the boundary or I shouldn't
say all the result in learning theory
but at least in the type of results that
we will describe and curiously we beat
this central limit theorem rate of 1
over square root of n which is something
you would guess if you knew that is a
random quantity is coming from some
distribution this is quite curious and
there is a explanation later now let's
talk about overgrow motorisation and
overfitting there will be a separate
section that I think either we'll talk
about the at the end of the at the end
of tomorrow on over a parameter that you
know overfitting but let's let's discuss
a few let's make a few observations
dimension D as was mentioned never
appears in the mistake bounds and
therefore G could be infinity we could
be working in an infinite infinite
infinite dimensional space everything is
still fine it's implicit somehow in the
margin but it's a different matter of
complexity it's not dimensionality as I
mentioned already perceptron is a one
layer neural network without the hidden
layer and there are d neurons so D equal
to infinity is infinitely wide neural
network without a hidden layer
and 4-d larger than n any end points in
general position can be separated and
therefore will always have zero
empirical error so nowadays everyone is
talking about fitting the the model the
neural network with too many parameters
to the training data well in some sense
this is already captured here you are
training a model with a huge number of
parameters it will definitely converge
to a solution that has a zero training
error and it still generalizes as we
just saw so some of the features of
recent - your neural networks is already
present in this very simple examples so
conclusions more parameters than data
does not necessarily contradict good
prediction performance as you just saw
perfectly fitting the data does not
necessarily contradict good
generalization complexity is a subtle
notion and much of the next couple of
hours will be on what are the different
notions of complexity so here dimension
is not the number of neurons is not the
right notion maybe there is something
else such as a margin and of course
margin is a strong assumption it's
stronger than no noise and so you can
even argue that this is unreasonably
strong assumption and that's fair enough
and then we will look for other
assumptions to make and about the
problem
that concludes that small section any
questions about the perceptron okay so
let's talk about the bias-variance
tradeoff so we just proved that the
expected loss of the final hyperplane WT
after its run - no more mistakes - the
Bayes error which is zero anyway is at
most one over n under this very strong
assumption that there is a later
separate with our linearly separated
with the margin this linear separability
means that the Bayes classifier belongs
to the class is also a linear classifier
and it belongs to the class with which
you're working or I should say there are
many of them and then you can choose one
and one way to relax this assumption
that there is a margin is to say let me
try to do out-of-sample let me try to
have a out-of-sample loss comparable to
the loss of the best linear separator
classifier even if there is no margin
assumption let's try to remove that
margin assumption and and redefine this
as the goal hoping that there is not
much gap between the loss out-of-sample
loss of the linear classifier and the
best overall that's a you know that's a
redefining the goal but this is a
something that we will do for the next
couple of hours again is to work with
some class of functions F and hope that
this class of functions captures the
relationship between X and the y and the
redefining our goal in this way means
that our target now is F sub F that's
the best-performing function within
class F as was mentioned
Ruggero so you can now think of
decomposing this the our goal as an
estimation error and an approximation
error a subscript F sub calligraphic app
is the minimizer of the expected error
within the crosstab and so clearly this
is some kind of a bias-variance tradeoff
making F larger means that you'll get
closer to F star so the bias is smaller
but then it's harder to estimate the
function it's harder to choose the good
function from a larger class based on
the data because variance is now larger
and vice-versa if you make F smaller
than you increasing the approximation
error increasing the bias but decreasing
the variance and there are ways of
trading of F and n under the names of
structural risk minimization of sieves
model selection but will not talk about
that so kind of a good guideline to keep
in mind is the following in simple
problems for instance linearly separable
with a margin we might get away with
having no bias-variance decomposition
the model is so simple that you can just
minimize let's say empirical data and
and that's your solution
for simple problems that might just work
however more often we have more complex
problems and we do need to have this
bias variance decomposition and for more
complex problems the our assumptions on
the distribution which we're hoping to
keep weak imply that this f star is
contained in a very large class and so
we can't just minimize empirical fit to
data over this large class and it's
better to introduce some bias in the
hope of reducing variance and again this
is a
this thinking is standard in statistics
and finally the bias-variance tradeoff
that we just saw here is not the only
way to do it in the final lecture the
fourth lecture we'll consider a
different bias-variance tradeoff which
might be better suited to analysis of
deep learning will see different by
experience the composition so any
questions at this point
yes in which which one is better my -
thing is that people never average so
let's see if I want to get them for the
details so these two approaches
correspond to SGD right with fresh data
on the out-of-sample objective when you
go once the other approach which
corresponds to minimizing empirical risk
and so for this problem they give the
same result there are there are problems
where they might differ but okay I guess
this would be a long
when they're different but it's good to
keep in mind these two setups when you
repeatedly going over the same data and
minimizing lost your target is actually
the empirical fit to data when you do
once you think of this as a the target
is the expected loss and you're doing
stochastic ratings
yes so what we're going to talk about
the two musician at some point because
not necessarily the case but it has the
larger it's harder to find facts yes so
we will not talk about optimization in
the generalization lectures but the rule
should be plenty
yeah of course that's all yes
so one might hope to use bounds like
this to explain stay practice some I'm
wondering how far you're willing to
interpret say sounds like the one you
showed perceptrons
if we're perceptron be like the
interpretation is very straightforward
sure well yes here's a look more pointed
question so if you're working with
linearly separable things ever you
thought there's a margin than with this
bound necessarily explain why it's
working one ohm I think so
so we did not depend on say what the
actual margin was oh the actual so the
actual margin the results if you look at
Kochanski function paper they show
concentration of the market or they
durable margin and they expect some kind
of closeness of photos so they can you
acted so the empirical Martin could be
close but it could still be too small to
you know the bound that was yeah that's
right so um I mean there are always
subtleties in the problem but if he knew
you would get a better result right III
I don't think it will ever without
knowing anything you can't get the you
know the the right thing right yeah I
don't think the purpose of these bounds
is to necessarily give you a number
that's third percent and that's exactly
what you and the point is to try to
understand what are the right
complexities in the problem you know
what governs generalization
come on yeah hey let's come back to that
as we go through these lectures okay so
my understanding is I have maybe another
ten minutes and then questions is that
so I'll start on different walls of
large numbers if you think about this
little sketch right this is the support
of the cat's distribution this is
support of the dogs distribution we've
got some data and then we we found a
hyperplane that separates the data
perfectly it might cut through the wrong
distribution but this cut is relatively
small as we showed right the error
probability can be controlled in general
this solution is an empirical minimizer
it has the property that it perfectly
fit the training data or in general
minimize the training error so what we
will do now is to try to generalize this
idea and to say when is minimizing
empirical laws a good idea when is it
when is it a reasonable idea to just
minimize the empirical objective and
what can we say about the out-of-sample
performance of this empirical minimizing
okay so now let's recap we're gonna
choose our model from the class app so
think of these as veer classifiers or
neural networks or whatever and it
minimizes the empirical error over this
class so we're trained the neural
network let's say to minimize the
empirical risk our work would found this
hyperplane once again our empirical risk
is that's a different notation this is
more of an empirical process theory it's
p-n think of this is the empirical
measure acting on this function in
sample was for pattern classification
this is precisely the proportion of
training examples that are so the
question is how does the excess loss of
such a procedure behave and once again
if I just know that the that a minimized
empirical loss even in this situation
it's not so easy to get the result that
I just showed from general principle you
all I know is you minimize empirical
risk
can I show that the out-of-sample
performance is 1 over n that's pretty
difficult let's see how far we can push
with a kind of a general what we do is
we write expected out-of-sample loss of
the model - the best in class and as
this Triple D composite take on the
composition expect that - the empirical
performance of the trained model plus
empirical performance of the trained
model - the empirical performance of the
best within class best according to that
expected loss
this is something we could never compute
plus again the same thing mine is the
best out-of-sample for the best model
okay now when you take expectation of
both sides what we notice is that the
second term is zero so sorry the third
term is zero and the second term is
given without expectation is non
positive because FN hat is the minimizer
or is a minimizer of the empirical walls
so by definition the second term the
second bracket square bracket is is non
positive so in expectation you can see
that the out-of-sample performance
compared to the best-in-class
is upper bounded by this strange
quantity which is the out-of-sample
performance - the in-sample performance
of the Train
now it's easy to see that the this term
is not zero if this function didn't have
the Hat if the function were not
computed from data this would be zero
but because the the because there is a
hat this function depends on the data
and so this is a bias this is a biased
estimate so in expectation this term is
nonzero and that's all the trouble in
the world is because of that so what do
we do there are different ways of
removing the hat and one way is just to
say well I don't I don't know where F
and hat is in my class it's a random
function it's a function chosen even the
data from the class but I know it's in
the class so that's the only that's the
only thing I know I will just take a
supremum and an upper bound the left
side by the supreme over all functions
in the class the very pessimistic upper
bound
now if it turns out that if the most
function is not curved it's not a
squared lost you don't lose too much if
you didn't have more assumptions on the
problem you don't lose too much in this
step but if you did something like
regression this would be you would lose
sample complexity or the rates but this
is just the first attempt so let's try
to do that once you go to the supremum
you observe that it's a supreme of a
absolute value of a zero-mean random
variable which is indexed by F and so
what the what the next few lectures will
be is study this supremum for which
purposes well we want to understand when
learning is possible because if this
goes to zero
in expectation then the left hand side
goes to zero and that left hand sides
going to zero with an is exactly what we
want and that's one but that means that
this is going to zero with large N and
that means that we're approaching the
best performance within the model class
okay questions about this
okay so we want to understand when
learning responsible wimped under some
sample complexity how many examples do
we need to get the right hand side to be
epsilon and if we get that then we know
how many examples we need to get
performance out of sample performance
epsilon close to the best in the class
but we also want to design new
algorithms and and one way to see it is
to say well if I know that my upper
bound is on this difference is some
quantity don't know that what I can do
algorithmically is to try to minimize
this plus that quantity because that's
the upper bound on my expected loss and
and in fact this gives rise to a penalty
a penalty term or regularizer
that can be used in applications so
they're they're kind of several
motivations for trying to understand
they're right on the side of this
difference questions it also depends on
the data set it does depend on the data
but we'll try to understand that in
expectations expectations both sides or
in high probabilities also there
this spring one it depends on the this
depends on the data this whole thing
depends on is taken also over to be this
you know supreme absorber functions in
the class or all neural networks over a
six data set for fix they just but then
we'll yeah statements because this is a
random quantity will have to measure it
in expectation or high probability
answer and just a point to say will
mostly concentrate an expectation
expected soup that's where most of the
difficulties and then high probability
is another layer of abstraction and
that's typically concentration which is
not too difficult that functions are
bounded
so in what follows will work with a
function class G on some space Z so just
abstract it so we don't have to write XY
pairs will just write Z and we we're not
gonna write lost of f of X comma Y will
just write G of Z okay so at this point
learning is going to be removed from the
picture and we're just going to
concentrate on an abstract class G which
is a real valid class on some space and
that's good enough questions this is
called the lost class L composed with F
and perhaps I will take every three more
minutes on this picture okay so and I
will leave you at that just on this
empirical process viewpoint so what we
have here is a zero-mean random variable
randomness is in the data there's a
Puritan performance and this is
out-of-sample performance F now does not
depend on the data and so this is a
zero-mean random variable but there we
have a supremo so for each function you
have a random variable has ever been
random variable and now we're looking at
what is the worst value of this
difference over the class of functions
and this is the empirical process point
of view think of on the x-axis you have
all functions this is a very hand wavy
the patient first
in blue you have expected value of G so
think of this as out-of-sample
performance the expected performance and
this is the minimum this is the
minimizer overall functions do you start
what would love to be close to G star
but we only have data now once you draw
data once once you have this drawn of
iid and iid points from the data from
from the distribution now you've got for
each function you've got the the
empirical value of that function because
data are random it's not exactly at the
blue line but it's kind of all over the
place now if you had drawn a different
set of data you will have a different
right but this is a picture you should
have in mind it's a as you draw random
data you get a random landscape of the
training loss let's say the empirical
value of over the functions and now
let's say this is the picture and you're
just trying to minimize empirical fit to
data or empirical value then you will
choose this function which is some how
far and it's not a good is it just it is
misleading the the location of this GN
hat is misleading because you've got
lucky or unlucky and it really dipped in
this far away part of the space
and the reason for that is is you there
are so many functions here that the
empirical picture is very different from
the out-of-sample picture so what you
have to do somehow is to to restrict
yourself well this is not really showing
but there is a gray box here which is
the class G so you're restricting
yourself to some class G of functions so
you're only looking at this class and
now if you're looking within that class
then the minimizer might be here
constrained to this portion of the
functions and the best out-of-sample is
here rather than here and it's clear
that if you make it very small the
fluctuations will not well hopefully
will not pull you in too far away from
from the actual out-of-sample picture so
that is the that's the picture that you
should have in mind for the next lecture
when Peter will talk about the empirical
process which is exactly these two
curves on the difference between these
two curves I think I will stop here and
take questions
[Applause]
yes how do you choose the subsidy well
if you're a god you would just choose it
- this is where we don't know the
distribution underlying distribution so
you know you're hoping that the neural
network would be a good model for
mapping raw pixel values into the output
by doing so you are choosing that class
right why do you do that I don't know
maybe there is some other choice but
that's a choice of the expectation
because because we know that it be
minimized expectation you're gonna end
up like end up by some function that
this modeling example is learning models
like oftentimes we end up like no it in
minimizing the empirical risk and if you
chose the global minimizer to go with
that miser that's exactly what we're
gonna be talking about when is it a good
idea to if you if you if you decided
that this is your model when is it a
good idea to go after the minimum of the
red curve and and and hopefully the
minimum of the out-of-sample on the blue
curve that's what you want the minimum
is going to be close to the minimum not
not in this space but in the in the
height right close to the global Bayes
optimal this is the Bayes optimal this
is the constraint optimum within this
model class so that's the best that's a
neural network that you could have
chosen does it make sense to train you
know to minimize loss with the training
data and get this point
that's exactly the what we're gonna
okay good so away with reconvene in 25
minutes and one announcement if you have
a burning desire to preserve an open
problem this afternoon please contact
Mateus do you want to stand up so this
contact treatment I like the semen on
the Box you can bombard in this
Authority convenient package